[Music]
hey everyone we are here at summer game
fest aka key three so what we've been
calling it um to talk to glenn schofield
about the callisto portable glenn how
has it been like you've got to show off
gameplay oh man it's uh it feels good
yeah i mean we've been
kind of hiding it for like you know a
couple of years so it's always good to
talk about your game that's for sure and
it had such a positive reaction at uh
summer game fest live what's been the
big takeaway for you on the dev team
um
i think just how positive everybody's
been i mean uh you know people have
their own opinions and man it's been
really positive for us so we've been
really excited about it and
i couldn't ask for anything better
and i mean so obviously since working on
dead space you know technology has
changed
graphics have changed i mean even
next-gen consoles how are you utilizing
not only what you've learned working in
the games industry for so long but like
how are you utilizing modern
technologies to help create you know and
elicit that emotion from players
right well you know um
both uh
both horror and sci-fi
uh
can really benefit from realism
sci-fi because
it's um
you know you're making you're making it
all up right it's a it's your
imagination
so how do you make
it real right you add rust you add grime
you have dirt you're like like you don't
know what that thing is but the fact
that you can relate to it makes it
better and horror
needs realism because you just want to
suck the player in right the more you
can make them feel like they're in that
environment the scarier it's going to be
so
the the new graphic systems the new
hardware the new um uh rendering
techniques ray tracing all that uh have
really helped uh us make a game that's
really realistic and even even the
characters look stunningly real um
so that's really helped the audio right
now you hear something especially with
headphones i hear something like there
now
we do that on purpose now we're like put
the monster sound
way up to the left so that the player
hopefully will be a little bit more
twitchy when they're looking around
right and that
that adds to like
a man what's behind me but then you want
to look forward so i think that's going
to help with the uh
with the scares and the tension and
stuff like that and of course the
haptics
which we're still still trying to get in
all the ideas we have into it but you
know snapping a bone or
you know uh that sort of thing and you
you want to feel that right i was gonna
say so there's me playing astros
playroom and just enjoying feeling the
snow beneath my feet and then there's
you lot going on okay let's snap a bone
yeah yeah you know um and i'm seeing a
lot more of this uh
um in in horror movies like zombies
where they're like contortionists and
and they're like look you hear the bones
cracking and snapping
so yeah we want to get that in there i
was someone's gonna ask you know your
feelings on horror and you know in
particular when you're approaching it as
a third-person game versus a
first-person game because obviously
first person you have that narrower
field of view whereas with third person
you are
still trying to engage the player in a
way that they are twitchy about their
surroundings but they have
i guess more agency they have more
time to react to things does that change
how you approach designing encounters
um
yeah i mean third person having's just
spent the last nine ten years uh making
first person it's a it's a different
game it's different animal right it's
all about your
your arms and your weapon i mean your
weapons are characters but in third
person
it's like
you've got to worry about just about
everything like uh
you know did something just drip on me
like you don't see that stuff in in
first person or
you know uh the change just dragged so
um and then of course the deaths the
deaths don't work as much you know and
third person man
you see the deaths um
you see the stomp you see all the action
that the player does
i mean it is definitely harder because
now you've got a billion animations yeah
um
but um
i don't know um
it brings you more into the
it makes you want to save that character
more because that's you you know so i
mean how's your approach to you know
speaking to dev teams over the years
especially uh working on horror games is
the philosophy of how much you want to
keep your player alive because obviously
in things like dead space and things
like the cluster protocol
you've got the gory just we still wanted
summer game first so you obviously want
your player to experience those yes and
you know feel that tension and feel that
there is going to be
consequences to messing up but how do
you also keep that tension
ramping up into you so you get to a
point where like you know if i'm playing
and it's like i died here so i'm going
to deliberately avoid this i don't want
to have to memorize it
right well you know players inherently
don't want to die yeah you die five
times and you're like man of yourself
you know so
um you you don't want that to happen um
but we know you're going to die in this
game
on and so but we we try and and we'll be
like
we we count all the time we're like
all right somebody can die three times
here and we're okay with that yeah um
you know then there may be some place
later in the game that's like you know
four times when we start to get to the
bigger numbers we don't want that to
happen we know it will happen but so we
know the player is going to die
um
and we know that the player is going to
want to try and keep themselves alive
yeah so it just
it's just the way that goes and then
when you do die
you are scared because you're you know
you're mad at yourself you lose stuff or
you got to start over again
or you've just got to go through that
scary spot again yeah so in our game i
know you want to keep yourself alive
yeah so it's it's not even like you get
the exposure
because you kind of have the inherent
fear that you're gonna die again you
know oh yeah yeah no doubt yeah yeah
yeah and you know you're gonna die yeah
yeah and you don't know how you're gonna
die oh interesting that's cool yeah i
was gonna say danger around every corner
yeah yeah
when it comes to working on the the gore
stuff and you know i was i was fielding
questions from my team because everyone
is so excited and they were like you
know someone brought up the you know the
mortal kombat team when they were coming
up with fatalities years ago yeah and
they were like
sometimes it gets a little heavy having
to work on uh you know inads being
ripped out in very creative ways and how
is the team uh approaching you know
creating these
just gruesome gruesome deaths over nova
you know it's only a uh
it's only a few people in a way you got
some animators who are doing it
you have your uh
your character uh creators who are
doing it a little bit
of course your rendering team
sounds pretty good
yeah so you've got about
30 people are probably working on that
yeah out of
line at 200 or whatever
and there were times when uh like the
rendering guys they're just looking at
this is gonna sound awful but it's it's
on the internet car crashes oh
no no as someone who grew up on like
rotten.com you know yeah yeah i've been
there yeah so
yeah they they get to a point where some
of them are like i've seen enough and
the others are like uh whatever now yeah
um but
yeah it gets heavy
i was gonna ask so it's kind of the
state of horror what's it been like you
know making a game
like this you know gaming development is
so much more expensive these days and
there is always kind of the feel that
something has to have you know take
something like marvel's avengers you
know it was a fantastic single-player
game and then they were like now you got
to have this online part of it you know
everything has to have this return and
it feels like
you know these
single-player experiences particularly
horror
especially to one's the um the scope and
you know just how
like
not expensive looking but you know like
how well maybe this game looks you know
i know exactly what you're talking about
yeah um and
you know we had to find the right
partner that was saying
i'm willing to let you make
a franchise yeah right um
because
on the beginning of this game
at the whole damn game it is it's just
huge investment because you've got
a new engine a new team
no mechanics right there's nothing you
can use everything is starting from
scratch as a matter of fact you don't
when you're working on a game like this
you don't even get the scares for like a
year and a half wow because you're
making the characters you're making the
enemies you're building the world you
have to build special effects
like when i was working on call of duty
we had 10 years of special effects yeah
so we could prototype real quick yeah
like prototyping for this game has been
boxes and stuff like that sort of what
you hear like old school um
so uh yeah there's a big investment
um i thank god that uh
that crafted
um took the chance with us
and took the plunge
and um
you know we we hope we make uh you know
more than our investment back
and that they can see
the future
of
of this is a franchise
so
it is a big deal but
we also saw this trend where like
everything's going online yeah oh
there's a big game that made it single
player there's another one
there's still room for single player yes
and but and i guess also it's like
it can live online in a different way in
terms of you know especially with
you know scares you know youtube twitch
uh kind of gives that online
injection um
i was gonna i was gonna ask obviously
when the game was announced it was gonna
be part of the pub g sort of wider
universe and then recently came the
announcement that it was no longer but
there are going to be ties are you able
to talk to a little bit about that yeah
yeah sure i mean we uh when we first
started when i i first joined them they
were working on this giant timeline and
and story and lore and everything for
pub g like
they want to make more games sort of in
that universe so they're like hey could
you fit in this like 300 years in the
future
i'm like
sounds like a pretty good idea you know
um we're gonna be different you know and
they're like well look we're we're uh
you know dystopian and uh
so
um we went along that way for a while
and then i don't know uh it was really a
while ago
i want to say a year or so we're already
um
not in that world right where
the story is going in direction
characters universe world everything and
so
it was just kind of we got reminded not
too long ago when i got a couple of
those questions where i'm like uh we
kind of got to announce that uh we're
not in that world anymore
we didn't want to confuse
the fans yeah you know they were like is
that a vr game you're making so yeah
that makes a lot of sense but
don't get me wrong and one of the
reasons why we're here is because of pub
g yeah i mean we're all fans of it
and
you might see little tiny things in
there won't have much to do with the
story but just i'm not and not in a wink
and i guess is there anything you've
been able to do
obviously you talked a little bit about
um advancements in technology but even
with regard to story
haven't you know gameplay been in the
back of your mind for a long time it's
like i'm just looking for the right
project has it been anything like that
it's just a more powerful machine
right so i don't mean just there's so
much you can do with it but it's not
like it
changes gameplay
like uh
like when we went from 2d to 3d which
probably none of it nobody remembers um
it changed everything
when you went from 3d to uh
vr it changed everything yeah but
for a new console it changes to haptics
it changes the sound it changes
the graphics it changes what you put on
the screen
um for us
i i'll get back to it just that
immersion that realism
um just
uh really really did help
um
but it's not like we went oh all of a
sudden we can fly outside the box yeah
there's nothing really no
incredibly weird i'm i'm gonna get some
designer tells me i'm wrong i'm just
gonna say you'll get a note on slack
yeah yeah they're like liar yeah
uh well glenn
callister protocol is coming out later
this year uh do you wanna tell the folks
at home when and uh when they can play
it december 2nd
not long to wait uh
hope you enjoy it
for more from summer game fest make sure
to keep your eyes peeled to gamespot